seitdem ich mit den Reisevideos
angefangen habe und auch hin und wieder
Nachtzüge teste steht der Polarexpress
in Finnland ins Land des
Weihnachtsmannes ganz oben auf meiner
Liste auch bekannt als Lapland Express
startet der Zug abends in der finnischen
Hauptstadt Helsinki und bringt die
Passagiere in 12 Stunden zum nördlichen
Polarkreis nach rowanemi dort herrschen
oft -20° und die Strecke soll echt
geisteskrank sein was ein Abenteuer und
ich wünsche euch viel Spaß mit diesem
Video und damit J Leute was geht ab
herzlich Willkommen zu ein neuen Video
ich hoffe natürlich euch geht es gut ich
befinde mich hier gerade in Helsinki es
ist arschkalt wir haben jetzt gleich 23
Uhr und hinter mir seht ihr den Bahnhof
von Helsinki ich weiß nicht wie er heißt
rauta tiesema jernwech Station und von
hier aus fahre ich jetzt gleich mit dem
Polarexpress aka Santa Claus Express aka
Lapland Express wie auch immer bis nach
rowanemi ins Land des Weihnachtsmannes
und ich glaube das wird richtig geil
seitdem ich mit den Reisevideos
angefangen habe stand das immer ganz
oben auf meiner Liste und ich dachte mir
aber wenn ich es mache dann so in der
Vorweihnachtszeit damit auch wirklich so
dieses Feeling rüber kommt und das am
Ende ein richtig niceses Video wird und
ja ich bin mal gespannt ich bin auch zum
allerersten Mal in Finnland ich war noch
nie in diesem Land Helsinki eine richtig
schöne Stadt ich habe mir hier heute
schon einiges angeschaut und ich bin
übrigens auch nicht alleine unterwegs
ihr sagt ja mal Alex du kannst doch
nicht immer alleine Reisen machen wir
heute auch nicht sondern oh sorry
sondern ich habe Marie dabei was geht
ich bin Marie und ich bin die Kamerafrau
und wir reisen heute zusammen ist auch
ihre erste nachtzugfahrt du wirst dich
denke ich ein bisschen erschrecken weil
so geil sind Nachtzüge auch nicht es ist
manchmal ein bisschen anstrengend wobei
ich stark davon ausgehe dass der
Polarexpress heute nach der beste
Nachtzug wird indem ich hier war und
auch dieses Erlebnis das ganze Drumherum
wird sicher geil also nicht lang labern
ab im Bahnhof und viel Spaß mit dem
Video Kanal abonnieren für weitere
reisevlogs und ja dann wollen wir
[Musik]
mal coole
Türen so dann gucken wir mal ah da
stehen die Züge so hier oben haben wir
c273 nach hanemi gleich 7 da steht zwar
noch nichts von dem polxpress aber das
wird ja auf jeden Fall sein wo ist den
gleich 7 ja ich glaube hier komm wir
gehen mal durch vielleicht steht er ja
schon da das Ding ist wir haben jetzt
gerade erst 22:10 Uhr Abfahrt ist in
einer Stunde um 23:13 Uhr also das hier
ist auf jeden Fall gleich 7 aber Zug ist
noch nicht da wir müssen uns eh noch ein
paar Snacks holen es gibt zwar an Bord
auch was zu essen aber man darf sich nie
drauf verlassen deswegen hast du
irgendwo noch ein Shop gesehen schauen
wir mal W haben wir noch eine Stunde so
dann holen wir uns mal noch ein paar
twets was gibt denn hier leckeres
Finnland ist auch wirklich ein teures
muss man sagen aber das sind ja alle
skandinavische Länder such mal was aus
das sind wirklich alles nur finnische
Sachen so was S deine Erwartung vom
ersten Mal Nachtzug fahren ich bin auf
jeden Fall sehr gespannt und freue mich
sehr und ich freue mich sehr auf unser
Ziel was ich weiß ist dass wir da
schlafen können und dass wir ein
Badezimmer haben stimmt und auch eine
Dusche und auch Dusche und das ist mega
alles was brauchen wer kann schließlich
schon von sich behaupten er hat mal im
Zug geduscht oder gibt ICS duschen
mittlerweile ist es vi4 Uhr und da vorne
kommt ein Zug ich gehe mal davon aus das
müsste der sein weil sonst fährtlich
keiner mehr ich bin dieses mal echt ein
bisschen gespannt Leute ich habe schon
so viel von diesem Zug gesehen und
gehört ich freue mich richtig das erste
Mal dass ich mich über ein Zug freue in
meinem
Leben
Zug so da ist er der fährt hier sogar
rückwärts rein Alter der ist auch also
in echt ist der echt ziemlich
[Musik]
hoch irgendwo müsste drafehen santaus
was hier haben wir's Santa Claus Finland
jetzt muss ich mal schauen unser Ticket
Wagen 53 213
214 also eine Sache die ich nicht checke
da fahren ja auch übelst viele Leute mit
die sich einfach nur hinsetzen aber man
muss halt dann wirklich 12 Stunden jetzt
gleich sitzen und das hat preislich
eigentlich keinen Unterschied gemacht
für uns wäre es sogar teurer gewesen
213 help
you I can help you sir ah sorry
sorry okay so angekommen so sieht das
Zimmerchen aus also es sind wirklich auf
Videos kommen so Sachen manchmal größer
vor als in echt das ist echt nicht groß
aber gut brauche ich auch nicht und wir
haben ja aber eigentlich sogar eine
Dusche wo ist hier eine Dusche der Raum
ist die Dusche der Raum ist die Dusche
ja echt jetzt ja oder warte mal kannst
du das guck mal kannst du das aufppen
nee nee kannst das glaube ich ausklappen
guck mal zieh das mal was jetzt dann
verdeckt das glaub ich die Toilette hier
ja ja du hast recht ach so dann kann man
das hier vormchen ah ja okay dann haben
wir doch eine Dusche eine
Klimmzugstange auch schaffst du ein
Klimmzug obwohl ist das ne nee ich
glaube das Rei nicht ab also ich muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich habe es mir
größer vorgestellt einfach aber die
Betten wirken gut ich hatte einmal schon
gute Betten in dem Nachtzug sonst war
das immer weniger komfortabel und das
gute ist auch man muss die Betten nicht
selber beziehen sind schon bezogen
Wasser ist auch am Start ach so guck mal
und hier haben wir noch eine
Essenskarte
dinneras mag weißt du was das lustige
gerade war die eine etwas ältere Dame
ist ja vor mir gegangen und dann habe
ich gesehen dass ihr Mann dachte ich vor
ihr geht und halt so langsam hochkommt
weil der oder die sah von hinten hätte
auch ich dachte das wä ihr Mann habe ich
die ganze
Gag dann ich nehme den Koffer
Hall ja perfekt einfach im falschen hä
wie bin ich dumm perfekt Leute wir waren
einfach im falschen Wagen aber jetzt
haben wir es hier finally geschafft
sieht aber alles eigentlich gleich aus
wie eben außer der sitzt außer der Sitz
da Filmen wir einmal raus warte mal ja
okay ich will jetzt einfach erstmal
losfahren und wir sehen uns dann gleich
irgendwann wieder so wir haben jetzt
23:12 Uhr ich hoffe ihr Können es hier
sehen das ist ganz geil kann man immer
sehen wie spät es ist und hier kommen
auch Lautsprecher Durchsagen und warte
mal ich glaube wir fahren h schon oder B
ich mir das ein AH wir fahren wow
tschüss Helsinki war geil hier wir haben
h eine Nacht verbracht jetzt geht's nach
ranemi hier liegt auf jeden Fall auch
schon fett Schnee in rovanemi natürlich
noch mehr hier waren jetzt -6° gerade in
rovanemi sind es
-16 also noch mal ein bisschen kälter
und durch den Schnee ist Finnland finde
ich extrem hell ich bin mal gespannt ob
man hier heute Nacht gut was sehen kann
wir haben uns gerade eben gefragt wie
die Omis da hochken stimmt ja das ist
echt also auf jeden Fall eine sehr wilde
und mutige Entscheidung von den Nachtzug
zu fahren aber fei ich man muss ja auch
im Alter fit bleiben ist übrigens wie im
Hotel man hat jetzt zwei zimmerkarten
kann man dann hier reinstecken hier kann
man es sehen und was mir auch auffällt
die Kabine ist extrem gut gedämmt man
hört zwar den Nachbarn aber die
zuggeräusche draußen hört man kaum und
das war in den anderen Nachtzügen immer
Katastrophe deswegen ich nie so gut
pennen konnte selbst mit neuscans den
Kopfhörern ich bin auf jeden Fall mal
super gespannt wie es hier wird aber
erster Eindruck ist echt gut ist zwar
ein bisschen klein und eng zu zweit aber
alles andere ist wirklich top und ich
habe nur 166 € bezahlt normalerweise
zahlt man glaub ich 230 für zwei
Personen in dieser Schlafkabine mit
Dusche aber ich gehe davon aus weil es
nicht so gut gebucht ist haben sie das
noch mal ein bisschen günstiger gemacht
auf Lock
ja also was wirklich ein bisschen
abfackt sind diese Durchsagen hier ich
hoffe das geht nicht die ganze Nacht so
ich glaube ich bleib die ganze Nacht
hier sitzen also so ein geilen Platz du
siehst überall Schnee und hast hier so
ein chilligen sitz jetzt müssen wir nur
noch Polarlichter sehen und ich bin
guter Dinge das ist natürlich auch ein
Grund warum wir das hier machen das je
weiter wir in den Norden kommen je
größer wird glaube ich die
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass es halt am
Himmel leuchtet und das habe ich noch
nie vorher in echt gesehen deswegen
dieses kleine Mädel neben uns hat gerade
Toilette abgezogen und laut geschrienen
weil das so laut war weiß ja das ist
halt wie im
Flugzeug Gummibärchen haben wir uns auch
gekauft cornis und Wasser das war's wenn
man frühzeitig bucht kann man sich das
Frühstück auch pre-ordern das heißt man
bekommt es halt morgens hier hin
gebracht zur Kabine ich habe den Zug
allerdings erst vor drei Tagen gebucht
da ging das dann nicht mehr deswegen
muss ich selber morgen früh zum restaur
Lon unds Frühstück holen aber das werde
ich natürlich machen heute Abend essen
wir nichts mehr wir haben eben noch bei
Piano gegessen und wir haben halt jetzt
auch schon 12 Uhr so spät sollte man ja
eigentlich auch nicht mehr essen ne und
jetzt warten wir darauf dass der
Schaffner kommt und dann gucken wir uns
noch ein Film an so Leute gerade war
auch die Schaffnerin da ich habe jetzt
nicht mitgefilmt was machst du da ich
bin gerade hier am Filmen die
Lautsprecher Durchsagen sind zum Glück
nur einmal beim losfahren und morgen
früh bevor wir in ranemi ankommen ich
musste gerade mein Ticket zeigen so
sieht das aus wir sind tatsächlich ganz
ganz hinten vom Zug also ich glaube da
ist noch eine Kabine aber wenn man sonst
jetzt hier links rum guckt ist dort
direkt Hal kein Zug mehr wenn man das
verstehen kann so marie war gerade schon
duschen und wie
war's super außer dass man die ganze
Zeit immer wieder neu andrücken muss ja
wie damals beim Fußballtraining aber das
ist gut warmerparend und ich hoffe es
ist jetzt noch genug Warmwasser für mich
da weil jetzt bin ich dran ich dusche
jetzt einfach in dem Zug wie viele Züge
haben das bitte ich glaube das sind echt
nicht viele vielleicht noch ein paar
Nachtzüge in Amerika oder so aber in
Europa könnt ihr gerne mal kommentieren
jetzt muss ich ein bisschen aufpassen
was ich jetzt zeige das Dingen kann man
umklappen und jetzt habe ich hier ja
eigentlich recht viel Platz und hier ist
so ein
Knopf so Bo es ist schön warm diger
einfach im
Zug das war's schon wir machen wir jetzt
hier schön frisch man muss ja immer gut
riechen und macht die Kamera wieder aus
nicht dass hier irgendwie noch so dumm
irgendwas gespiegelt wird ne man weiß ja
nie eine Sache wollte ich noch loswerden
erstmal Kur mal unter der Zähne die
Dusche da hab ihr stehs zwei Flügen mit
einer Katsche geschlagen und ich hatte
mir vorgestellt man kann das Wasser
nicht so gut regulieren also ob es kalt
oder warm ist aber das funktioniert echt
optimal ist wirklich ein richtig gutes
Duscherlebnis hier und hier ist auch
direkt Shampoo bei wenn man sein eigenes
nicht dabei hat bin begeistert Dusche
war sehr angenehm wir gehen jetzt jeden
Moment schlafen und jetzt passt mal auf
Leute Arm Licht aus WoW und das ist
wirklich einfach nur geil du guckst hier
raus das war ein Helsinki nicht so auf
den Tannen lag kein Schnee weil der
Schnee relativ alt war schaut mal nach
da hinten boah sind das nicht schon
Polarlichter ich bin mir
unsicher aber es sieht verdammt cool
aus aber ich glaube da hinten ist
vielleicht auch eine Stadt oder sowas
ich bin auf eure Kommentare gespannt
aber in Deutschland habe ich so den
Himmel noch nie gesehen und was man auch
ganz klar sagen muss das kommt auf
Kameras immer krasser rüber als in echt
das haben mir viele Leute erzählt und
ich kann mir das auch gut vorstellen
wegen Belichtungszeit und so ein Bums
aber ich könn mich echt die ganze Nacht
hinlegen nur noch draußen
gucken
[Musik]
so Leute wir haben jetzt mittlerweile
2:1 Uhr gerade schon kurz eingeschlafen
gute Nacht bis
morgen so Leute guten
morgenin und gut geschlafen also wir
haben Hal schon 9 Uhr und es ist noch
ziemlich dunkel ne aber es sieht echt
aus wie be be
kurz Zähne putzen und dann holen wir
Frühstück so sieht der Gang aus noch
keiner wach in 5 Minuten sind wir in
Hemi um 939 uh dann kommt noch tervola
murola und ranemi ich suche jetzt auf
jeden Fall erstmal das Restaurant car
hier sind anscheinend schon Leute
ausgestiegen hier ist ja niemand mehr
also ich hätte eigentlich gedacht dass
90% von Helsinki bis nachanemi
durchfahren weil das denke ich so eine
beliebte Strecke ist aber Anschein
nicht
car 58 58 so okay thank you und so sehen
übrigens die Wagons aus wo man sitzen
kann ich muss sagen da ist so ein
sleeping car natürlich schon Premium
[Musik]
ne Leute es ist einfach
-12° boah wir sind jetzt hier gerade in
Kemi sieht schon echt cool aus ne so
schnell wieder rein
[Musik]
frü okay Frühstück ist da wir haben noch
unsere cornis die wir gestern ang
gekauft haben dazu gibt's jetzt bei
phänomenalen Ausb wir fahren sofort über
so eine Brücke ein Cappuccino und ein
cisson und jetzt schauen wir mal raus
wow Alter guck mal hier sogar im Fluss
ist Eis es sieht so verrückt aus also es
sieht halt wirklich aus wie beim
Weihnachtsmann oder Lars der Eisbär
diese diese Serie die habe ich früher
mal geguckt und wir haben halt jetzt
gleich schon 10 Uhr und die Sonne geht
do erst in ein halben Stunde auf also es
ist schon echt cooles Erlebnis mit
diesem Nachzug zu fahren was aber noch
geiler wäre wenn das ganze Zimmer so ein
riesen panoramafensseite weil die
Aussicht ist ja wirklich schon geil und
so kann halt nur einer immer cool
rausgucken also zumindest so auf
entspannt ne und wie war deine erste
nachtzugncht ser gut manchmal wenn es
geruckelt hat bin ich aufgewacht also
teilweise hat auch echt manchmal richtig
stark geruckelt manchmal dachte ich das
fährt ein anderer Zug noch auf der so
angedockt wird ne ja aber ich habe auf
jeden Fall noch keinem Nachtzug so gut
geschlafen wie hier
[Musik]
heute
frisch gemacht umgezogen Mütze auf warme
Sachen an hier ist es ja noch mal
deutlich kälter wir haben jetzt gleich
-15° in rovnemi schon und ich glaube die
nächste Nacht wird es noch kälter Sachen
sind fertig gepackt in 20 Minuten sind
wir da ich muss sagen die Nacht hier war
echt super entspannt ich habe so gut
geschlafen wie noch nie in einem
Nachtzug zuvor alles gut gedämmt man ist
gar nicht so wirklich wach geworden von
so ich sag mal lauten Geräuschen die der
Zug macht manchmal hat ein bisschen
geruckelt aber es war echt top auch das
Bett super bequem also diesen Zug hier
in Finn kann ich auf jeden Fall
empfehlen wenn ihr mal nach wanemi re WT
sehr sehr geil jetzt schauen wir mal
noch ein bisschen raus und dann steigen
Wirich aus ich freue mich der Tag wird
bestimmt richtig geil und heute Abend
ist auf jeden Fall das Ziel Polarlichter
zu sehen ich bin auch echt gespannt auf
ranemi was uns da erwart ich kann mir
noch überhaupt nicht vorstellen wie das
dort aussieht habe mir auch keine Bilder
vor angeschaut ist es eine kleine Stadt
ist ist einfach nur ein Dorf paar Hütten
keine Ahnung so leute schaut mal hier
ri so Marie aussteigen hier ja wir sind
da
[Musik]
geht aber eigentlich von der Kälte also
es fühlt sich gar nicht so kalt an wir
sind angekommen in
rovanemi also ja erste ein ist ganz nett
jetzt hier der Bahnhof aus keine Ahnung
warum hier LKW steht wir gehen jetzt
erstmal hier ins warme und dann erzähle
ich euch wie es weitergt hinter mir seht
ihr jetzt noch mal den bahnhhof und wir
machen uns jetzt zu Fuß auf den Weg ins
Zentrum erstmal was essen das sind auf
jeden Fall gut 1,6 km in diese Richtung
so ich zieh diesen Scheiß
Koffer ist wie ein Schlitten
mittlerweile angekommen hier im Zentrum
von rowanemi glaube ich zumindest es
sieht alles echt ziemlich modern aus um
uns rum also ich habe es dir ein
bisschen anders vorgestellt wir sind
auch gerade ein bisschen los weil wir
nicht wissen wo wir hin sollen jetzt
gerade weil wir auch erst um 16 Uhr in
unser Hotel können aber nichtsdestotrotz
würde ich das Video jetzt hier beenden
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen wie fah
du den Nachtzug sehr gut also ich fand
richtig cool mal im Zug zu duschen und
ich habe sehr gut geschlafen echt aber
ich schlaf immer gut deswegen aber es
war sehr cool eine sehr gute Erfahrung
und das coole war dass man die ganze
Zeit rausgucken konnte und dass wenn man
aufgewacht ist dass man schon angekommen
ja das stimmt also für mich war es auch
der entspannteste Nachzug mit Abstand ze
von ze also okay ze von ze ist
übertrieben aber es war schon richtig
geil und richtig geiles Erlebnis
abonniert den Kanal für weitere
reisevideos und wir sehen uns hier in
zwei oder drei Tagen wieder da kommt
schon das nächste Video wir schlafen in
der Hütte im Wald bisschen Polarlichter
anschauen ich hoffe es wird geil ich
habe bisschen Angst oder bisschen
Respekt sage ich mal so weil wir sind da
glaube ich ganz alleine aber wird schon
klappen ne
ciao